well Jane this really is a box office
set of local elections seven out of ten
voters in England are eligible to vote
and it's the biggest electoral test
we're going to see before the big one uh
the general election which we expect
next year so really it's a moment in
time which will set the political
weather and what it's going to tell us
we hope is whether or not kirstarma
really is on course to win the next
general election can he do it can he end
over a decade of Tory Rule now they're
of course subplots to the main drama the
main story of the night about kirstarma
there's the question about whether Rishi
sunak is managing to stabilize the
conservative brand there's also another
fascinating subplot which is the battle
for the blue wall can the liberal
Democrats really eat into the
conservative vote in the Tory shires and
the anecdotal level so I'm getting in
tonight is that they really are making
Headway but the undoubtedly big story is
whether starma has the sort of momentum
he needs to win a general election so
can he win Key Battlegrounds across the
country places like Swindon where he
launched the campaign places like Medway
in Kent where he ended the campaign can
he win back in the red wall places like
uh in tease Valley where I was last week
so there's so many seats up for grabs
and so much to look out for now where
are we tonight when we shake out what's
happening in the Tory Camp it's one of
resignation they're hoping that if they
contain losses to about 500 seats that
they can write this off as mid-term
Blues I was talking to one senior
strategist today who candidly admitted
to me anything above 700 whatever the
party chairman Greg hands says anything
above 700 seats would be to quote this
person an absolute absolutely disaster
disastrous and that person told me we're
going backwards in most places crumbs of
comfort I'm told in the East Midlands
for the liberal Democrats well they come
from a high Watermark they did really
well in the comparable set of local
elections in 2019 but they still think
that they could make big games could
they make a gains of over 150 seats that
means that they are in biting distance
if you like of potentially challenging
the conservatives and key marginals in a
general election and then what about
Labor well I'm told the mood at
headquarters is buoyant that they are
winning back I'm told support in
Battleground areas from T side to Medway
to Swindon and the West Midlands one
strategist told me tonight that by the
morning they think that they will be
able to argue that the party is on
course to forming the next government
but of course the question really is can
care starmer Dazzle in this set of local
elections in the way that Tony Blair did
back in 1995 before his Landslide
Victory labor have a huge task again
ahead of them it's a gargantuan ask to
win an outright majority from where they
are but we're going to have a better
sense tomorrow of whether kierstama has
it in his grasp to become potentially
the next prime minister